[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host open
phones this hour as we bring common
sense to your dollars and cents in a
world where common sense is a is so rare
that having it is like having a
superpower open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five
we're going to start this hour with
baton rouge brett is with us hi brett
how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
great got a question here
dealing with a little emotional i guess
cell of possibly some equities that my
father had
given me when he passed away about four
or five years ago
oh about
188 000 on the house i have a 15-year
mortgage just refinanced about a year
ago so i guess 14 left
and we've had some pretty tremendous
gains in the stock since i inherited it
a little over
probably a million in gains and
i guess he never sold it i grew up
we never sold it collected the dividends
and now it's finally reached a point
where i think
it's in my best option to sell just a
piece of it to pay this last piece of
debt off
and i guess i just needed some
reassurance because i have never once
thought about selling you
okay
well the the total investment account of
equities is worth what
1.6 million
and 180 000 pays off your house
yes
okay
so
i mean
like 10 percent
right it's like none of it
you're barely touching it
that's very true and i guess that was
the emotional part of it it was given to
me
and you know i guess watching him he
just collected dividends he just held it
held it and i feel like holding it for
these past four years has been a
tremendous gain but
telling a piece of it i guess that's it
you you you somewhat answered it for me
right there it's a small piece and now
here's the other thing what this does
bring up though
is it does need it brings up
you know what your father did
with these stocks
um was
you have to decide
was that his
unwritten unsaid instruction that you
should follow no matter what happens
or was it good for him at the time
but he would expect you to think on your
own
into the future as to whether that's
still a good strategy
which is i'm i'm guessing number two
would be the thing
because right it'd be pretty weird for
him to look at you and go never sell
these stocks
i mean that would be something someone
would say about the family farm
or about the family bible or about your
great great great great grandfather's
musket you know or something like that
never sell that would make sense but
never sell stocks
really no i don't think he said that did
he
no no sir not at all so you're not
besmirching his legacy
his intent he's not in heaven frowning
at you
if you sold them all
and diversified and put them into
something else that you believe to be a
better investment with good critical
thinking skills
very
yes 100 i agree with you so i think you
kind of got to get that going because
the the the bulk of my conversation with
you before i started of your explanation
to me was all about what grandpa and
what papa always did and
it's worked for me
uh but i i want you to be independent in
your thinking of
his memory we can honor his memory best
by continuing to do good critical
thinking thought
into the future this is not a
family heirloom it's stocks
correct yes sir so yeah in other words
if you feel like that these things have
run their course
and you've had a good run but you don't
really like the future
it'd be okay to liquidate the whole
stinking thing and put it in mutual
funds and pay off your house that'd be
okay with me that'd be my tendency by
the way
because i don't play single stocks
i don't like the risk it's too much risk
for me
but uh but i you you have to work
through the emotional part of it and go
okay what were dad's wishes here what
was his wishes what did he want you to
do and so what i want my kids to do is
live on principle
after i'm gone
by by principle i mean on
a series of principles that give them
good critical thinking skills good
spiritual eyes on the world
uh those kinds of things and and then
given all of that they can make a lot of
decisions that were different than the
old man made
but one of our principles would be we
don't borrow money now that one i would
expect them to hold too
you know one of our principles would be
we're always generous i would expect
them to hold to that principle
but you know the nuance and the tactical
of exactly how you do some of those
things i i want to leave them free to
make judgments because the world does
change good question that's a very good
call sabrina is with us in pennsylvania
hi sabrina how are you
hi dave doing great big fan thanks for
taking my call well thank you how can we
help
i am wondering if i should sell my
rental property to buy a home or if i
should buy the home and keep the
property
do you have the cash to pay for your
home
in cash no more no mortgage
the new home no we've got about
80 000 saved for a down payment um i've
got about 60 000 left on the rental
property which was a condo i bought five
years ago
and never lived in it for various
reasons but i'm just not sure if that
would be good passive income for my
husband and i uh rental property is
great passive income
but the i i still would sell the condo
and use all the equity to put plunk down
on your home and get your home paid off
as fast as you can then buy rental
property with cash
because here's the here's the effect
let's pretend you already owned the new
home
okay
and it had and it had a bunch of equity
in it and you're living in the new place
you're thinking of buying can you get
there in your mind right now
yes okay
and then you woke up and you didn't own
this condo
and you woke up one morning said you
know what i'm gonna go take out a second
mortgage
to go buy this rental condo
you wouldn't do that
no you're right i wouldn't and in effect
whatever the equity is in the condo that
you could have put down on the house
it's almost as if you're borrowing that
against the house to keep the condo does
that make sense
yeah yeah i guess i am so then
would you recommend i mean i guess i
would have to look into it but i would
use that money to put a further down
payment on the house and not just do a
typical done okay got it yeah this one
is as big a possible down payment as you
can put because the goal is get the
house paid off as fast as possible
because when you're 100 debt free then
you start piling up money and if you
want to buy some rental property for
passive income that's a wonderful time
to do it with cash and that's what
sharon and i have done we started that
many many years ago
and um
we've paid cash for all of our
properties because you know the rumor
ramsay doesn't borrow money so um
you know it's exactly what we've done
but sometimes if you reverse engineer
these decisions meaning like pretend
like it wasn't there and i went and made
it happen
it makes the answer readily apparent so
i personally would sell the condo
and that's what you were asking is what
i would do i'd sell it and put as big a
down payment on the house as you can get
that house paid off as fast as you can
that's the shortest distance between
where you are right now and wealthy this
is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost
the average family saves over 800 a year
go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
well this is a big week here at ramsey
ken coleman's book uh the brand new book
[Music]
from paycheck to purpose uh comes out
number two on the bestseller list so a
great best-selling book again from ken
coleman has done very very well thank
you for all of you that supported that
process
and we launched the pre-sale on my first
book that i've done in eight years i
haven't done one in a long time i've
been pretty much helping the
personalities get their books out and do
that for about a decade now the last
best seller
last major book i did was a national
number one bestseller i did it with
rachel cruz my daughter called smart
money smart kids it was eight years ago
so uh we're doing another one haven't
done one in a while like i said but uh
we got got it done
and it comes out on uh
but on january the 11th is the street
date that's the date we will ship it to
you it'll be in your mailbox or on your
bookstore shelves that day
and uh it's on sale as of yesterday or
as the day before yesterday so um it's
called baby steps millionaires
how you'll become a millionaire if you
follow the baby steps now a lot of
you've heard a lot of this stuff before
but we've laid it out here in such a way
that it is um undeniable
that you can get there
uh we lay it out for you spiritually
mathematically
uh with case studies of all the tens of
thousands of millionaires that are there
because they follow these baby steps
that we teach
we taught them starting back in 2003 in
the total money makeover book
and so there's uh you know 20 years or
so of people out there running around
doing this and we talk to baby steps
millionaires every day so we talk about
the things that people believe that are
mythology about millionaires and we talk
about the exact steps to follow
to get there if you're looking for get
rich quick or some kind of prosperity
gospel thingy it's not that at all this
is simply if you plant corn
you should pretty much expect corn to
grow
that's kind of how life works right it's
cause and effect sowing and reaping baby
steps millionaires on sale now if you
buy for twenty dollars right now while
it's in pre-order you get the audiobook
for baby steps millionaires the e-book
for baby steps millionaires and the
legacy journey
which is a book i did also about wealth
uh the audio book and the e-book of it
uh the baby shops millionaires live
stream which will happen in january a
ramsey smart tech tax tax filing our tax
filing software
um
is going to be there for you for free to
file your taxes this year and a ramsay
plus
subscription 30-day free trial which
gives you access to financial peace
university and the premium version of
every dollar our budgeting app so all of
this for 20 bucks
just because you pre-ordered baby steps
millionaires
and um thank you already a whole bunch
of you who have bought the book in the
past 72 hours and we really appreciate
that um and of course we'll continue to
let you know all about it as it comes to
fruition and actually ships out the door
the second week of january kathy's with
us in macon georgia hi kathy welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave it's such an honor to get to
talk to you you too what's up
well i just i really want you know how
excited i am is the timing is perfect i
said i'm gonna call um
we just sold our home because of all the
council i've been listening to through
your program and being in your financial
peace university program off and on
but um due to certain circumstances but
we ended up with about a 200 000 net
after commission
on the sale of our home but we don't
have a home so we started renting so we
could get settled and decide what we're
going to do we're in our 60s
and i want to know what to do with that
money we have a 44 000 debt uh remain to
be paid off in our debt snowball
and my husband thinks we should use all
the money to pay off the snow the the
debt and i said this is our home we need
to treat it like our house even though
it doesn't have those kind of boundaries
on it right now because it's what we
need to buy a home
when the time is right when we get there
so we'd like to know what dave would do
i'd pay off the debt
you win instantly even if you're in our
at our age yes ma'am i was i told him
you would say that three days ago today
i'm terrified to do it because because
of the market well here's here's the
thing
you you there's two pieces to you having
stability in your golden years
financially a paid for house and no debt
and so we've got to do both we've got to
do both to get you there
now your long-term plan you didn't buy
you didn't sell this house in order to
rent for the next 10 years what was your
plan to buy when you what's the what are
you buying what are you buying what are
you thinking
we are really praying through this
season because we felt like we made a
huge mistake in our last home you know
we just got ahead of the cart and
and uh
we're really just being tentative right
now about what we're going to do but
you're going to buy something you're
going to buy something right okay right
and what is your income right now
remember oh i'm sorry let me tell you
first of all we do want to pay for as
much as we can for in cash without
having to go with a mortgage i agree our
income today
our our day income today is 160 000.
okay and so what are you thinking if you
were to guess today and you don't you
don't have to you don't have to put this
in stone but just what you're thinking
today if if i sat down with a cup of
coffee with the two of you what would
you all tell me the price range you're
probably going to buy in is
350 to 400. okay and you got 150 to put
down because i just used up 40 of your
44 of your
200. i like it one bit i know i don't
either but i like it better than you
being in learn to be a shaver good i've
learned so now you don't have any debt
you can save more
correct
okay so i actually want to make more
money too i don't want to earn any more
i actually want to start good
income on my own good okay so we got 150
we need
we need another 200 000 and you make
160.
okay so if you bought a 350 000 house
with 150 000 down took out a 200 000
mortgage and paid it off in four years
that wouldn't be that big a deal
well what's the payment on i haven't
done that calculation well if you pay
off two hundred thousand in four years
is 50 000 a year
right out of 160 and you live on 110
when
i know right yeah you could do it you
could even do more than that you might
do it in three years because you're a
saver and everything you know
but three or four years from the time if
you bought that house this summer for
350
uh you know in the next six months or so
you bought the house for 350 and you put
down 150 and you had a plan to pay it
off in four years you're going to have a
great retirement a paid for nice solid
350 000 home that you bought with wisdom
you took your time and you didn't make
the mistake like you did on the last
house and you don't have any debt in the
freaking world except a small mortgage
that you're going to knock out really
fast and that sets you up for us a
quality golden years
so well done well done well done well
done i love it proud of you
it's good stuff
so the point is that if you have that as
your plan the four years from today if
you bought a 350 000 house today with
150 000 down you'd have no debt house
and all
then i'm not as scared paying off your
debt today the low 44 000 worth of debt
and paying off that little debt
causes what we just outlined to be more
likely to happen
versus you're running around with money
going out to the 44
and you're still trying to do this other
thing over here
so i think you need to pay off your debt
asap and then i think you need to have a
short term plan to knock out whatever
mortgage you take out i think your plan
of a 350 is a very reasonable
plan
but get after it kiddo it's not a 10
year plan this is a three or four year
plan skid it get it open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five here's what's interesting
if you just change your mentality from
i'm always gonna be in debt worth a
30-year mortgage and you just change
your mentality you just take the current
balance on your home and you start
dividing it out by chunks
like i just did her 200 000 by four
years that's 50 000. that's a chunk
right that's 4 000 a month basically
making 160 you can do this like a hot
knife through butter i mean come on this
is very very mathematically doable but
until your mind does it and you unpack
it and you go wait a minute i could do
that
you have that kind of light bulb over
your head like in a cartoon
you know a little light bulb comes on
and a little cloud over your head you go
oh
yeah
if you'll start looking at your debt in
chunks like that and do big math instead
of trying to figure out all these little
nuanced things
then you can get it paid off and you can
have a whole different mindset about
wealth
and a whole different mindset about your
generosity too
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
most of you know this but ramsay
solutions is located in franklin
tennessee just a little south of
nashville and franklin is a wonderful
small town mayberry rfd basically and
we've located our
our homes and our offices here for many
many years and um for many years in our
old building and now in the new building
for the last two years you can actually
come into our lobby get free cookies
that are homemade and they smell so
stinking good when you walk into the
lobby free coffee
that's all made just for you and all
kinds of goodies and a full bookstore
and all of our shows uh a lot of our
shows that is this show included are on
the glass and so people come in sit and
eat our free stuff and watch this show
which is kind of like watching ugly
paint dry but hey you can do it and we
love having people visit and we
appreciate you hanging out and sometimes
when they drop by they did so with an
appointment that they set up through
miss kelly to do their debt free scream
and we have this cool little miniature
six-inch high stage that's the debt-free
stage it's got a little emblem it says
debt free and standing right on top of
that debt-free emblem is connie hey
connie how are you hi dave i'm good good
to have you thank you nice to be here so
uh where do you live i'm in pittsburgh
all right have fun well good to have you
in nashville and all the way down here
to do a debt-free screening sir how much
did you pay off at 90 000. okay and how
long did this take 30 months okay two
and a half years and your range of
income during that time uh when we
started it was about 180
000 a year and
now it's
work optional
[Laughter]
whatever i want to do there's a story
here and uh ninety thousand dollars
worth of what kind of debt it was our
mortgage your mortgage you're dead oh
house and everything yeah look at these
weird
people good good for you thank you thank
you well done okay so tell me the story
what happened two and a half years ago
made you decide we're knocking the
mortgage out well
that was the end of the story the
beginning of the story was uh my husband
tim and i
met
in december
got i had our first date in january got
engaged in march and married in june of
what year uh uh
2003 we got married okay yeah so um it
was second marriage for both of us and
my sister elaine is who introduced us to
you
she knew that it was both of our second
marriages and we really wanted to be
proactive about our marriages because
the
both of our other ones had men ended in
divorce and we just didn't want to go
down that road so money was a part of it
and from where he came from and where i
came from we didn't grow up with any
money and we just really wanted to do it
right so we met you and um
attended one of your seminars in
pittsburgh in person yeah i didn't have
the money to pay for it so i volunteered
oh cool i have my volunteer like no one
else shirt still love it to this day
love it
um fast forward so we did we paid off
our consumer debt had children had life
all that in the meantime so we've been
consumer debt free for
several years now which was great um
and then for the mortgage
um
we just decided it was time but you know
we had already raised the kids and
everything um they're still i have 16
year olds in high school twins and a
daughter who
actually just got engaged this last
weekend yeah yeah that's fun
so what we decided to do was pay off the
mortgage just to be the last of it and
to be done with it and we wanted to have
it done by the time the twins graduate
high school
so that we could help them with college
um we didn't really plan on paying for
their college but we wanted to help them
if we could so our goal was to have the
paid off which is june of 2024 so
addison and nina would graduate and we'd
be able to help them twins and colleges
same time is a little tough yeah so
we were going to do that um
2018 tim was diagnosed with leukemia
and um
we thought we had a beat
and um
he passed away earlier this year i'm so
sorry
but that was the last of it we started
to pay it off
and we were meeting in the middle for
the girls graduation date
um but when i got his life insurance
from his work i went ahead and finished
and paid off the
house
don't do that you'll make me cry
so you're making me cry so so uh
wonderful milestone but bittersweet it
is you weren't supposed to be here
without him that's not right no no
that's the hard part yeah he's uh he's
much too young yeah
how old was he 57 yeah and you guys were
married for what almost 20 years 18 yep
yeah like you've done this before
wow well i was going with the 2003 part
so yeah
oh my goodness yeah thanks
what a tough year yeah
so i know
i wanted more to tell our story because
with our journey it wasn't just
get out of debt and then go on with your
life
we we're also coordinators we've
coordinated i'm on our fifth class
so we had done it five times but
currently and irwin's around here
somewhere he's helping me hi erwin
but um
we have coordinated your class a couple
of times and it was so important
we didn't know it then right
but now we did every step of the journey
and if we would have not paid attention
to the insurance lesson
because we went out and we got
catastrophic insurance and we got our
life insurance in line both his and mine
i would be a completely different story
i would not be standing here in fact the
girls and i would probably be bankrupt
because as you can imagine
a bone marrow transplant is super
expensive just that alone is over a
million dollars and if we had to pay 20
percent of that
and we've done he he treated for three
years so we would be absolutely
financially devastated and instead like
i said i'm
i'm fine the girls are fine we're fine
and uh it would just our lives would be
completely different how much life
insurance did y'all have well 10 times
with tim's was a million
yeah plus i on the other side of that so
we were paying off the house as soon as
we got the house paid off
um we were only 40 000 short of being
millionaires already
so this just doubled it then yeah and it
this is so funny to say and terrible
right because you think million dollars
a lot but when you have to live off of
that for the rest of your life
millions not a lot no it's not no it's
not it's
better it's better but i can't touch
some of it because it's it's our
retirement you know you're still too
young i'm still too young yeah so the
work's optional works optional yeah
i heard that part earlier
yeah well i didn't know we were gonna
get there the way we got there but we
did get there right i'm an entree
leadership person too um i owned my own
business
um
and
because i followed you there as well
i had a huge emergency fund through
covet and everything and we didn't miss
a beat because of it so
yeah you had covered leukemia and
everything else yeah but but you were
the third pig in the brick house i mean
you had everything built out just right
and strong but you don't know it at the
time well you knew what you you knew
you'd check the boxes you just didn't
realize how important they were right
exactly yeah yeah and now when you get
the other side of it life insurance is a
big deal and
being debt-free is a big deal and having
emergency fund in the business with
retained earnings and one at home is a
big deal and having a plan for their
kids college is a big deal and it's uh
it's the only thing that makes
um what you've been through even
tolerable tolerable yeah barely
tolerable yeah and if you had all that
stacked on top of this it would be
it would just be unseemly it'd be wrong
it would be you know it would be
crippling yeah i'm so sorry yeah thank
you so sorry for what you've been
through thank you i'm so
proud of him yeah how he took care of
his wife his kids
yeah and what he did what a great and
that's what i talked about that in my
fpu class i'm like look when we started
this i said look guys
you know i don't want to be debbie
downer but sorry to anybody named debbie
i don't want to be dead karen i got a
bad life
i am now here and i heard um but um i
don't want to be debbie downer but what
what a tremendous
legacy he left for us and it's not a
downer it's it's honoring his legacy
it's honoring his memory because he was
a good man and he did a good job of
taking care of his family he's a good
man
proud of him
all right connie we're going to
celebrate with you
with a little bit of a lump in our
throat with you all right
connie from pittsburgh ninety thousand
dollars paid off in 30 months making 182
i'll work 101 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two
one we're debt-free amen
[Applause]
wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
well i went out and got to have my
picture made with connie at the break
and give her a hug and wow what a story
hey the reminder is this um
when i tell you to go see zander
insurance and get 10 to 12 times your
income on you
you're 57 years old it doesn't cost that
much a million dollars is freaking cost
of a pizza
and um
you know you need to take care of these
types of things
and as she said it feels like you're
checking the box you don't have any idea
but you make make sure your stinking
health insurance is in place
make sure your life insurance of 12
times your income i mean if you make
fifty thousand dollars a year you need
to have five six hundred thousand bucks
on you
your spouse makes seventy five thousand
dollars i have 750 to million on them
and then you take that money and invest
it it will replicate the income that you
are no longer bringing to your family if
god forbid something happens to you and
i we've done detailed research none of
us are getting out of this deal alive
a hundred percent of us are gonna die
it's just a matter of when
and it's a matter of what it's gonna
look like when we're gone with our
family
that counted on us
get your stinking insurance in place man
get your wills done
78 of americans die without a will
it's about the same percentage that are
broke too by the way
i wonder if there's a correlation
between taking care of business and
taking care of business
oh there is
hello
you know do your do do your grown-up
stuff boys and girls get the will in
place make sure the life insurance is in
place make sure your health insurance is
in place and
um oh if you're a renter and you're just
getting started
make sure you have a renter's policy
it's only a couple hundred bucks and
that then when somebody kicks your door
and steals your junk you can get your
junk replaced because it is junk
probably was when i was renting
wouldn't have taken much to replace it
you get about twenty thousand dollars
worth of coverage for theft and fire
and at least get you a new bed if
something happens right hello
so you know you these basic now i don't
want you to buy a bunch of gimmick
insurance but the basic insurance
policies are the defense mechanism and
and some of you are only playing offense
and you you can't out earn your
stupidity you have to play defense and
offense and i've i've done it all wrong
i understand i know but go take a take a
lesson from a connie and say wow
you want your spouse standing there
going he or she
has graduated they're in heaven
but the family is in really good shape
because the person that left was so
responsible
such a grown-up
that's a big deal y'all it's a big deal
go to xanderinsurance.com
and get a quick easy quote there is you
can be blown away how cheap this stuff
is and people just don't follow through
and get their business taken care of
scott's with us in fayetteville north
carolina hey scott welcome to the ramsey
show
hey mr ramsay thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
uh so my wife and i are trying to figure
out our next financial news as we go
through a
career transition for me and a
geolocation transition for both of us um
we're currently on baby steps four five
and six um but as we change locations in
the country i start a new career and she
changes jobs and takes a pay cut uh
we're wondering if we should just stop
all investing right now
hit pause and start again in a year once
we're more stable
while we figure out all the mechanics of
what's coming up next
well i don't know why it would take a
year
well realistically probably closer to
six months but yeah if we plan for a
year then it's easy to do in six months
no if you're playing for six months
you'll do it in six months
fair enough um the uh uh
i mean i just i get the idea that now is
the net effect going to be a pay cut for
the household
uh yes we're looking at dropping from
about 2 30 a year down to about
130 a year
why
uh just while i work on getting my next
job
i'm sorry i'm transitioning out of the
oh you're going out of the military what
you're coming out of the military uh yes
i'm
yes oh okay and you currently make how
much
uh about 102 a year
okay and you you're gonna leave the
military win
expecting
march 1st
okay and what do you do in the military
i'm an officer in special forces
thank you for your service
what's your plan in civilian life
uh looking at getting into project
management or uh going back to school
get my mba
okay
i'll probably do both at the same time
and product management should pay more
than what we're talking about what does
your wife do
uh she's a nurse practitioner and why
can she not do that in the new city
uh she can which is why we think her
income is going to drop down to about
that you know 125 130 level well a
product manager you know with your
experience going right into it working
on your mba at night ought to be able to
make close to what you're making now and
if she makes the same as what she's
making now i don't know why we're taking
a hundred thousand dollar pay cut
yeah it's just looking at how long it
will actually take to find that job by
circling my resume um yeah
almost i'm gonna send you ken coleman
i'm gonna send you ken coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose which will help
you short circuit that process because i
don't want you to uh i don't want you to
miss two weeks of pay
we already know that we have from now
until march to find a job my goodness
people are hiring like bananas out there
so you ought to be able to land this job
way before you got plenty of time to
work on it you're not just putting out
resumes though i mean you're not just
filling out applications you're gonna
follow a precise
seven-stage process to do this and i'm
gonna send you ken coleman's book to
help you do that okay so i you know i i
think what you're doing here is battle
planning for worst case scenarios and
the problem with that what i'm pushing
back against i don't want that to become
a self-fulfilling prophecy you follow me
i got you you're tactically trained for
everything to go wrong and that's your
plan that's how your brain works that's
what you've been doing for all these
years am i wrong
no that's basically exactly what i'm
trying to do yeah and uh so what you
laid out for me i don't want that to
become your destiny i want that to be if
the whole battle plan goes sideways but
the plan ought to be we get in and we
get out nobody gets hurt okay
okay you with me here i mean you're
you're gonna she's gonna move her career
money over and you're gonna move over
and start your mba while you're working
full-time and all of this starts march
1st thank you for your service sir
this is how we're going to do this okay
so let's lay out a positive battle plan
and then if you want an exit plan a
worst case scenario and extract i you
know whatever you guys call that stuff
um you're impressive human beings what
you do in the way you're trained to
think in the middle of extreme violence
is amazing
um and so but i just what i don't want
you to do from a business perspective a
career perspective is create a
self-fulfilling prophecy so i want you
to lay out a positive thing and then
execute exactly what needs to happen to
cause that
desired future to occur
which is a little different than battle
planning okay we have worst case
scenario in the back of our mind that is
there is a trap door there is an exit
strategy
but we really are developing this where
there's a high probability of a
successful mission
and um i don't know if i'm using the
right words or not but i i think i am
so hang on i'll have laura pick up we're
going to send you a copy of paycheck to
purpose and
you know your
your training for execution on things
sets you up
uh for project management like nobody's
business dude you are highly qualified
to walk into that right now
and if if you want to come over here at
ramsey work project management we'll
talk about it because i i know how your
brain works
hey thank you open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money see here's the thing
that you want to be careful of and king
coleman talks about this all the
time
what you're doing where you are is more
important than what the company does
where you are and more important than
your job title is where you are
you're the pastor
of a church that runs 15 million budget
annually
okay you're not a pastor if you're
transitioning out of
that line of work into the business
world
you're a guy who's a ceos run a 15
million dollar
top line organization
non-profit or otherwise you've run a lot
of expenses you've done a lot of hiring
and firing you've been involved in a lot
you need to think about your skill sets
that you're developing not the heading
under which they fall
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america we are so
glad you're here dr john dolone ramsey
personality best-selling author of the
book to fight redefining anxiety he's
with me we're going to talk about your
life your money if you've got mental
health and boundary and family issues
he's here to help with that as well
we'll weave in together and make sure we
get your question answered from every
possible angle the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five harrison is in louisville
kentucky hey harrison what's up
hey hey dave thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
hey okay so uh i am engaged to be
married um my fiance and i are almost
done building our house um
so we are completely out of debt except
for the house
and we have our three to six months
saved up
and i want to start paying on the house
and just knock that out but she really
likes security and she wants to
continue to save and not pay as much on
the house and i was just kind of seeing
like what you thought about that
when are you getting married
when am i getting married um as soon as
the house is built
why'd you pick that order
um well we kind of decided to do both of
them at the same time it's like jumping
off of it's like jumping out of an
airplane and then trying to find where
your parachute is
uh yeah we
we got engaged and then started building
now when will it be complete
approximately
um
january february okay
all right
because here's the answer to your
question there's not a we
until you're legally married
because legally there's not a way
all right okay if you die today without
a will
she's got nothing
except what's in her name
whose name is this house in
uh it's in
my name oh
okay so she she doesn't have a house
if you die today without a will
there's an example of what i'm talking
about
your mom and daddy got a new house
if you die without a will today so
number one either go get married by uh
thanksgiving or go get a will done by
thanksgiving okay number two
um
there's a wii after you're married
number three
uh no you don't need more than six
months of expenses set aside you have
zero debt except a house and you're
attacking the house and by the way a
paid for house is a greater element of
security than a larger emergency fund is
okay so she really wants security
security comes from the paid for house
um and uh
so it now the thing you may want to
investigate because one of the biggest
things we fight about in marriage is
money
um
you may want to investigate what the
lack of where her insecurity comes from
that's so extreme that she violates that
she wants an extra pile of money beyond
what any financial planning
expert i mean the three to six months of
expenses is kind of a standard in the
financial planning world i didn't come
up with that
that's been out there for 50 years
and
hardly anybody says oh have a year just
to be safe
i just never see that or hear that
because you should move on with other
things at some point rather than just
piling up cash that's making you nothing
but i would want to know you know what
what's
you know is there the way she grew up
that family got foreclosed on three
times or they're always having to move
because her mom misbehaved with money or
what what is driving this
this need for an extra large umbrella
just in case it rains do you know what
that answer is
uh no i don't know what that answer is
um do you think that's a correct
question to ask
uh yeah i can definitely see why you
would ask that question and i guess i
should try to see if i can figure that
out more um i know that it's not just
like money she worries about a lot of
stuff she's just like that kind of
person just worries about a lot of stuff
kind of like expects the worst all the
time and so like
if you know our car would blow up or
something like that that would
completely drain the fun
and then we'd have to like start all
over again so i think that might be her
reasoning why she wants more than that
what do you make
um i make 40 a year she makes 30.
so 70 000 a year
so if you had fifteen thousand dollars
that would be approximately three months
of expenses
um and that would not drain your
emergency fund if your car blew up
right because i should just probably buy
like a two or three thousand dollar car
there well no i mean you can put an
engine in it for six or seven thousand
dollars and you still have nine thousand
left over if you had fifteen yeah or buy
a five or ten thousand dollar car i to
me the here's the the broader question
you guys as a married couple was about
to get married
is a great conversation to have as
you're entering into being with this
person forever is asking what are the
things that make you uncomfortable what
are the things that scare you out out in
the world what are the things that bring
you joy you should know those things
about the person as well as they can
articulate them before you marry them
and that's a good discussion around this
whole emergency fund thing and then the
other thing you do is um what i just
played on you there was a dr john lonely
trick
facts are your friends
you described a fear that the facts were
illogical
oh my car blows up it blows up my whole
emergency fund not that not unless you
have too small an emergency fund or you
need to drive a porsche right doesn't
matter well yeah i mean but i mean if
you have if you have 15 or 20 000 in
your emergency fund which would be three
to six months of expenses in your case
you wanted six months minimum because of
her insecurity so so we're really
looking probably 25 or 30 000 in your
emergency fund and if you have that
i don't know what kind of car fire
you're about to have dude but that's a
pretty serious car fire so that doesn't
match up you know when you say if i if a
car blew up it would drain my no it
doesn't that's the facts don't line up
and so one of the things i've learned to
do and i didn't know i was doing it
until dr deloney taught me i was doing
it but that is if you lay out the actual
dollars and numbers in these worry
scenarios
it takes the power out of the worry it
diffuses the worry it diffuses the bomb
or it points it it highlights the one
that is a real problem that we got to
solve yeah and then you go oh now okay
that one
yeah okay we're gonna have to get
another job and work for two years well
or do we buy insurance for that thing
there you go you know because i'm not
going to have an emergency fund won't
take care of that that's right and uh so
i gotta have something to alleviate the
worry but
most of the time when you give
numbers and timelines
and details to your worry
it uh it defangs the the worry that's
right it pulls the claws out of it
that's right and so you it takes the
poison out of it and because 80 of what
we worry about never happens anyway dale
carnegie used to say the other 20
you know let's divide it up into the
things we can do something about the
things we can't do something about now
we've got almost nothing to worry about
yeah because you can't do anything about
nuclear war or biden spending money you
can't do anything about that at all
except vote next time there's a chance
that's the only thing you can do but so
what you've got to do is get up off your
butt and exist in this inflationary
world
that is real
so
what can i do something about what i can
not do something about so that's the
problem spending all your time watching
fox and cnn is you you all you do is
worry about stuff that they want you j
ginned up about right instead of going
and living your life
so what a gift that would be huh wow
what would happen in america people
would start liking each other again
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today kendra is in dayton ohio
hi kendra how are you
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
okay baby step six um
we have
a house that's worth around 400. we owe
250.
um
we are at a 22-year fixed we couldn't
get it down to the 15 at this point
we have about 140 000 worth of repairs
and updates and things that we need to
do
uh to sell we're looking to sell in
three to five years and downsize
so
i recently
got a better job so the shovel's a
little bigger so i'm trying to figure
out do we pay down the mortgage or do
the updates
uh what's your household income
it's around 200 now good
so if you do the up i mean if you pay
down the mortgage and you don't do the
updates how are you going to sell
um exactly yeah so i think you do the
updates what in the world is wrong with
this house 140 000 on a 400 000 house
falling in
uh
yes and no it has um
it's just some parts are dated and was
when we bought it
um but it just matched what we needed
for our family yeah but what's wrong i
mean what are you talking about doing
for a hundred and forty thousand dollars
yeah anytime someone says repairs and
updates
that i always want to park those
apartments yeah
it's bowls it's bold because the kitchen
and bathrooms need updates and this is
per realtor coming in and saying okay
here are things i recommend in order to
get you know the best price for the
house kind of thing and within our
neighborhood
um
and so
it's a deck where the wood is literally
falling through somebody fell through
the steps so
it's it's a
air conditioning unit that needs
replaced it's
roof it's windows
siding
those are more of the repair side than
the updates the kitchens and the
bathrooms and flooring
wow
you guys have let this place run down to
nothing
we were doing the steps and that was the
struggle you just now got to babysit
four five six
uh yes okay cool yeah that's good only
within the last six months number one
separate the updates and repairs do the
repairs first
okay the deck that's falling is not
expensive number one number two it's
dangerous fix that
the heating area
like 20 for that
twenty thousand dollars
yeah and that was one of these
it's
large
and so that was one of the cheaper bids
okay we'll just try to figure out if
there's a different way to skin this cat
that sounds a little bit
you know there's
that still sounds out of control
the first one was 40.
okay
they all sound out of control
one of them sounds twice as much out of
control as the other one but still it's
it's wood and that is out of control
right now yeah okay well bottom line is
you need to you just need to segment
these items make a list and prioritize
them and begin the cash flow of them
through them number one item is most
dangerous number two is next most
dangerous then once you get past
dangerous stuff or leaking or repairs
and get over into updates maybe you do
some of the updates maybe you don't
maybe you just sell a house with an
outdated bathroom and
that was that yeah exactly that's very
struggling or do we refinance no
it's 100 you're trying to get out of
that we're not trying to add right that
was not one of your questions right you
make 200 you have three to four years to
do a hundred and forty thousand dollars
worth and so if you divide that by three
that's fifty thousand a year you can get
it done in three years and just make
your list out and just systematically
begin to work down the thing it's not
all one project at one time
correct and when i was talking refinance
i was talking about putting money
towards the principle to get it down to
the 15-year fix not burning against it
yeah well i i don't need to pay to
refinance to do that you just pay extra
on the mortgage
but we're not you're not able to do that
till you get this stuff done whatever
you choose to do to get the house market
ready
whatever you choose to do is the more
you study it the more you think about it
and the more you get bids on it
um and and by the way i'm you know
in the next six months do as little of
it as you can
because let's give some of this
craziness time to
some of the crazy to bleed off
of the construction world
because the construction world's in full
on crazy mode right now yes and so let
it you know let's not get in too big a
hurry
uh because lumber might come back down
matter of fact it probably will it's you
know once they start
bringing the trees out of the forest
again you know that kind of stuff it's
it's a supply demand issue
and so um
you know uh but but uh you know the way
you eat an elephant is a bite at a time
and that's how i would get at this i
want to i also want to make sure over
the next three to five years
i've made this mistake a couple of times
dave
i have a goal that's three years away or
five years away so i'm going to try to
get through a school program or
something like that
man
i i lose three years of life
because i don't like where i'm at i'm
always looking at what tomorrow's gonna
be and so i wanna balance that
140 000
we got to get you're not going to get
all these things done and all of a
sudden the sun's going to come out this
is going to come out anyway so make your
plan work towards these things and then
enjoy the house while you're in it and
sell it and sell it at some point just
sell it call it a day yeah you know i'm
done i'm out of here drew's in raleigh
hi drew welcome to the ramsey show
hey what's up chris how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
so i have a question i am 20 years old
i'm making about forty one thousand
dollars a year right now i have
uh twenty thousand in cash and twenty
thousand invested in a mutual and a roth
and in the
near future probably about the next five
years or so a marriage you know that
would be coming buying a house
um and stuff like that so
i had a question on is
or if you recommend being gazelle
intense for a few years to build wealth
i don't have any debt so i was curious
if you get intense for a couple years in
the beginning to build a wealth if that
would be worth it or if you
would suggest you just stick with the 15
that you recommend
well you don't have a house payment
today and so the 15 is not what we would
recommend we'd recommend that you max
out whatever retirement you can while
you're meeting some of your other
savings goals
see the the
yes i would be intense to use your you
know
i'm not sure it's gazelle intense
gazelle intense is you have absolutely
no life until you get yourself out of
debt
and i i
don't think i'm going to prescribe that
for you but i think you would be very
intentional
versus intense and say okay
i'm gonna have this segment of my money
that i enjoy and all the rest of it i'm
gonna use to pile up and build wealth
during this short period of time i'm
gonna be really intentional and i may
have a little smaller enjoyment budget
than some of my buddies who blow their
entire freaking paycheck
uh because i'm grown up beyond my years
i've already matured beyond my 20 years
here which you have just by asking this
question you're pretty impressive young
man
um and so yeah i think that's
intentional but when we're talking about
gazelle intensity we're talking about
you have no life at all yeah until you
get your dad gum debt paid off and
that's that's the best way to get out of
debt that's not necessary for you to
have a really
sweet situation five years from today
and i think you gotta look at what are
you not doing meaning if you have a
traditional eight to five job and you go
home you're gonna spin from five o'clock
till nine o'clock playing video games
in your 21 get another job
start
work and grind if you've got friend
opportunities to hang out with your
buddies and create community of course
do that stuff but i'm a huge fan of
people in their 20s really busting it
and getting after it but like they've
said man you got to breathe too you got
to breathe yeah intentionality just
means that you know we're not going to
go
from friday night to sunday night and
spend everything we made in the previous
five days which is what most people do
particularly at 20 years old then they
spend the next three weeks trying to pay
it back yeah and trying to figure out
what how we're going to eat because now
we are getting money to eat next week
and so that happens all the time so you
know we're just moving way
to the other side of that coin but this
idea that you sit at home and do
absolutely nothing
and you you sheep out on every single
thing and you don't buy a bed you sleep
on the floor or something you know no
we're not saying do that go on a date
yeah yeah enjoy and have some money set
aside for enjoyment
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net and
get one thousand to twenty five hundred
dollars off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
two
i can't see the screen james
thank you okay so in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage tyler
and jessica are with us hey guys how are
you hey y'all how's it going great man
so how much debt have you guys paid off
that is about a little over 68 000. very
good how long did that take
25 months good for you and your range of
income during that time it started about
59 ish all the way up to now it's
right at 70. very good good for you guys
awesome so you're getting after it yeah
so where do you guys live uh sparta
tennessee sparta awesomeness very good
not far just over the road over the hill
just yeah just over the hill
a couple hours huh yeah not too bad what
kind of debt was the 68 000. oh man we
were pretty normal i listened to the
show every day and i hear all these
screams and how they're normal and
i was just the same we were just the
same pretty normal there's a
car loan credit cards
personal loans just anything you can
think of except
student loans yeah wow yeah good for you
guys
so uh excellent job so tell me about it
when did you start on this journey you
started 25 months ago but what started
you on this ramsey journey
well in april of 2019 we decided that we
wanted to have another baby
and we wanted to provide the best life
possible for both of our kids
because we seen our debt that we were in
we actually
what kind of encouraged us to
start the dave ramsey plan was because
we sat down one day before we bought our
house and we looked at how much we were
eating out each month
and it was ridiculous we were spending
like five to six hundred dollars a month
eating out
[Laughter]
we didn't have any control over our
money if we had it we spent it and we
just we didn't care um at the time and
so we decided that we wanted to have
another baby
and so we just started trying to attack
our debt
and then we got pregnant sooner than we
thought and so we started stockpiling up
everything and that was probably one of
the best things that we could ever do
was really follow that to a t because
whenever our son was born he had to be
in vanderbilt for three weeks
and he came home on a feeding tube for
three months
and so because we had the stockpile of
cash we didn't have to worry about
anything because we knew that we were
taken care of regardless and even
through it was a very very challenging
time it really rocked our faith you know
we had to be
we really had to be strong in our faith
with god through all of that but because
of that we could focus on what god was
doing for us because we didn't have to
worry about any money at all yeah
so
so he come early or just had some issues
or what well he came three weeks early
but he had a birthing injury so
whenever he was born
they had to resuscitate him
and send him back to he had he had to be
rushed to vanderbilt they didn't think
that he was going to
be
like that he was going to not be able to
walk he wasn't going to have a much of a
life at all they thought he was going to
stay on the feeding tube for the rest of
his life even mentioned he may even
develop cerebral palsy at some point
yeah none of that happened none of that
happened he's running around here like
crazy oh i saw him out there he's
screaming at the top of his lawn
that's him i love it
very cool yeah i love it i especially
like it now that's great good for you
well good news that's good news what's
his name his name is aiden and how's
aidan yeah and how old is he now he's 19
months all right cool we have another
one out here her name is emery and she's
six and she's sitting here just like a
little princess yeah she is a princess
and she knows it
i love it very good okay so aidan and
what emery emery and so you all got
scared and you got a dose of hard hard
life and then what got you on the
journey
well just we wanted to provide a better
life for our kids than we had
you know our parents did the best they
could with what they had but we both
grew up really really poor
so i didn't want my kids to have to go
through that you know the house that i
lived in growing up was falling apart
you know but we just we made do with it
you know really humbles you down in life
um so i didn't want my kids to ever have
to go through something like that i
think so
we originally hearing heard about dave
ramsey from high school
but he didn't think nothing about it
sure yes and then we got married and she
actually mentioned hey why don't we
don't you remember dave ramsey i said
yeah
that was pretty much the end of it
of course i was in 2017
and then uh yeah we are around here
tyler
yeah
yeah
then you know
we started our marriage with didn't have
much debt but
i
took responsibility
and uh well it was more of a
negative impact on the life because i
was the one that got us into the debt i
kind of got this car fever one of the
new the new stuff and hey why don't we
go get a credit card if we can get it on
zero percent it must be okay
that kind of thing but then reality
started setting in
because as she mentioned we were wanting
to have another baby
and so we started looking further into
this dave ramsey
stuff
you see it with different eyes when you
need it yeah you really do
it's good i understand well well done
you guys i'm proud of you yeah yeah so
excited what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is you paid off
68 025 months well um yeah so i tell
people that the key of getting out of
debt is for one you got to be content
with what you have if you're not ever
happy with where you're at now you won't
ever appreciate where you go out in the
future
so i tell them that and that they have
to get on a budget budgeting and knowing
where you're knowing where every dollar
is going to is the biggest thing
and i think the key
for me would be
patience
i learned a lot of patient to have
patience during this process to have
patients not only with myself but with
the actual process process
if you're not going to go get another
job then find something to sell if you
don't have anything to sell then just
just find other ways to make money and
just be patient with the process
we literally sold everything in our
house
we sat on lawn chairs for a few days
we even sold we even sold one of our
vehicles which was a big majority of the
of our debt yeah good for you guys way
to go you guys incredible yeah well if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one's right
absolutely you set yourself up to take
care of these two babies very well done
now you can buy that beautiful wife of
yours a couch my friend
that's a good thing i love it all right
are we going to get emory uh in the uh
in the or or aiden in the either one in
the debt-free screamer were they just
going to watch i think they'll just
watch okay that works for me all right
tyler and jessica from sparta tennessee
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for you to go on and be baby steps
millionaires we also got a copy of the
total money makeover for you for you to
give away to one of those friends that
have been making fun of you while you
were doing all this stuff yeah
maybe get the maybe get one of them
activated yeah they told us we were
crazy yeah well you are you're crazy
like a fox so there you go well done
very very well done tyler and jessica
aidan and emery 68 000 paid off in 25
months making 59-70 from sparta
tennessee count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready three two one
we're
[Applause]
[Music]
there is something about having an
emergency
and there's nothing quite like a brand
new baby who's
uh got some medical challenges to take
your breath away put your stomach in
your throat and make it stay there for a
while
and there's something about being in
that situation with money versus without
money money doesn't make it all better
right money doesn't make it go away but
it lowers the level of trauma it gives
you an option yeah
it gives you you know it gives you the
ability to concentrate on what matters
not what matters and what doesn't matter
yeah and this couple didn't have a model
of what this looks like growing up and
so they had to just lean all the way in
on these baby steps and they followed
them all the way through man how cool is
that very cool good stuff good folks
well done y'all well done this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i kind of think it's too soon to start
talking about christmas but it's not too
soon to start thinking about being ready
for christmas
thanksgiving's a couple weeks away
here's the deal me and the rest of the
ramsey solutions team we're already in
christmas mode
uh because that's what we do we just
love christmas around here so that's the
deal and we're giving away cash as part
of our christmas cash giveaway every
year we celebrate christmas with our
ramsey show listeners and our ramsay
show
christmas cash giveaway it's become a
tradition this year we're giving away
five hundred dollars every week which
means you want us to start as soon as we
can so we've started and a grand prize
of five thousand bucks you can enter to
every day to increase your chances of
winning once a day is about all that'll
work for you other than that we pull it
out but then we do a drawing and someone
wins 500 bucks every week go to
ramseysolutions.com
slash giveaway and you can get in on the
giving as well we've got all kinds of
life-changing gifts for your family your
friends our famous 10 sale
on over 40 best-selling books our
envelope systems
you can get stuff like rachel cruz's
newest book know yourself know your
money for 10 bucks the total money
makeover for 10 bucks which is number
four on the best seller list this week
there you go this year uh forget the
one-time use presence and gift a
lifetime of hope shop the 10 sale ramsey
solutions.com sign up for the free money
hey our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time you save even more use the promo
code ramsey to get the best deal all
right today's question comes from
caitlin in colorado
caitlin says my ques my husband and i
are on baby steps four and six our
children's college funding is already
covered through my husband's gi bill we
paid off
175 thousand dollars in 27 months while
working six jobs between the two of us
wow while that feels great the problem
is i'm exhausted well no kidding yeah
i'm tired of working 70 hours a week and
i don't want to miss out on this time
with my kids i see in the everydollar
app what the extra income can do for
family vacations buying the things we
put on hold and baby step 2 and paying
off the house so i feel like i have to
keep up this crazy pace
how do i change my mindset from the
hustle and grind to get the debt done to
this is a crock pot in the rhythm of
life so i can finally enjoy what we're
working for for so long
[Music]
man that's a
that's a question about identity that we
get a lot dave yeah how do i how do i
turn the gazelle off how do i let the
gazelle just rest and start grazing
again yeah when you finish your baby
step three and you've got your emergency
fund in place we tell you to change from
a gazelle intensity just to
intentionality just being doing things
on purpose so
here's what's new
what will never be the same because
you've changed the shape of your brain
permanently
what will never be the same is is that
you will never again
look at the every dollar budgeting app
and not think oh i could do this
i can do that i can do this you're
always going to have that thought
because you've retrained your brain to
actually pay attention instead of
letting this happen to you you're
happening to it
and so that's great news
and and you've identified what the
problem is you're tired
and so you know you look at the every
dollar app and you go well i'm not gonna
be working as much and so we won't be
able to do this and this and this and
this but now you're doing it on purpose
yeah and that's fine yeah
i i like to there's a there's a three
prong decision making matrix here you go
practice curious and facts
i want you to practice
working fewer hours and then i want you
to feel how uncomfortable that is and be
curious with yourself why is it why does
it feel so uncomfortable right now that
i want to hang out with my kids instead
of going to deliver pizzas tonight
and then i want you to sit down with the
data your body's going to be telling you
we got to keep wrestling we got to keep
running what are the facts the facts are
you paid your debt off
you're okay
and you're gonna slowly practice
retraining your body that you're not in
danger anymore and now it's about how
much fun can you have and like they've
said be intentional about your life and
i
i
i some folks dave i just i've just come
to understand some folks and you may be
like this you hit a light switch just
off
i'm good i saved up my money and i'm
gonna do this thing
um i found my wife's that way
we got the money we're good and i keep
thinking all right but what about this
what about this and so i got to practice
let's lean into it practice and then i
get better and better at it and then i
quit thinking about it after a while
so here's what happens
your nervous system resets right
and so you're driving 30 miles an hour
for a year
and then you step on the gas
and your heart rate changes your stomach
comes up in your throat adrenaline is
released and you're doing 90.
and then you set the cruise on 90 and
you ride along about two hours on 90.
then
you reset the cruise down to 55
and you feel like a turtle like you're
walking you feel like a turtle
you're like what happened yes i i
thought you know but at first 90 blows
your mind right but then you reset and
you drop back down to 55 after you've
got your nervous system reset at 90 then
it just feels like this is a crawl and
you're still not at 30. well you're
double you're almost 2x which you were
and here's the here's the demon here
your body gets addicted to yep the
cortisol and adrenaline that gets
released at 90. it begins to beg you go
back to 90. we feel we get we get that
that drug hit at 90. and you got to
retrain your brain that you know and
what's worse than that is 90 won't 90
won't deliver it anymore you got to go
110. because you got you once you get
associated with that you got to go on up
again and so you just have to force
yourself to go oh my god this you know
because when those white lines are
coming at you like
and then they're coming at you like dink
think it feels like you're dying feels
like the world's passing you by i'm just
are we crawling here
are we ever going to get there
you know and but your what your nervous
system resets and it does it in any area
of your life once you've handled here's
another example okay i talked to people
that they you know they made sixty
thousand dollars their whole life
and then they start making a hundred
thousand dollars
and they make a hundred thousand dollars
for ten years and they lose their job
and uh they get a new job making 60. i
said well you're not going to keep
making 60. because your brain is reset
your nervous system is set at 100 now
you're going to gravitate the
gravitational pull is going to pull you
back to the hundred but you've never
been there before the first time up that
hill is a steep climb yeah but it it's
like rolling down the hill to get there
the second time because you're you're
everything about you your way your mind
works is set on a hundred thousand now
yeah you said it just changes everything
yeah and you can't go back you don't you
know once you've stretched you can't go
back so you're going to experience when
you turn this down
the feeling of you've gone from 90 to 55
but or 60 but that's still twice as fast
as you used to be going so you're fine
and what most people go wrong is they
feel that downshift
and then they try to hide from it they
try to they numb it they they get into
all kind of crazy addictions because
they feel like they're going too slow
they're going too fast and that's why i
want someone be curious about it go oh
yeah we're going 60 and what's the data
the data is we're going 2x what we used
to be
the other speed wasn't sustainable it
was just for a season we had to get out
of that yeah you're going to get
arrested yeah or you're going to crash
your car or your engine is going to melt
down right and now let's be curious
about it and we're going to practice it
and then 60 is going to be a great
cruising speech the rest of your life
yeah yeah we'll be just fine you have
some more seasons of 90 and some of 40
but it's life you can spike up if you
want to spike up again if you need to
but you know it's not sustainable you're
exhausted yeah you're exhausted yeah and
you need your your brain is telling you
your emotions your body your fatigue
levels talking to you and so listen yeah
listen
and there's nothing wrong with that
everything you're doing is right
everything you're doing is normal the
beautiful thing though is
you now know what 90 feels like yeah
and so it's no longer a theory for you
and there will come a moment when you
have to go 90 again and you'll you'll
it's
say
i can do it yeah and you know i've had
to do that after covet you know i've had
to kick my hours and the work
productivity that is you know i i'd
slowed back and
but i'm right back up where i was yeah
because there's some you know stuff
happening at ramsey and i got to be back
in the saddle and here i am so here we
go baby you know and i'm back on the
stage i'm back in the
media and back in writing books what do
we got to do to get you know because
this is what it takes to go right now
but it's not for everything not for
everything
it really wasn't hard to get back there
either yeah i know it's probably and
that's the thing it's part of me like
just give me an excuse to go 90 i just
want to know
and hey uh i want caitlyn i want you and
your husband yoko celebrate you paid up
make it have a marker
go have a party mark the moment and then
say what's next don't just continue into
the trip and drive
yeah yeah
man
pretty stinking incredible i love it
dr john deloney good hour
james childs is our producer laura
johnson filling in for
kelly daniels today on the phones and
associate producer role i'm dave ramsey
your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john dolone ramsey personality
is my co-host today his show the dr john
dolone show is where
oh it's an amazingly popular podcast
where they talk about life and
boundaries and relationships and mental
health things that are going on so we
will talk about all of that and your
money this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five ally and jessie
are on the line with us in montgomery
alabama to start off this hour hey guys
how are you
hi it's actually just ali now my husband
had to go get the one-year-old oh
that'll work okay good for him
[Music]
so what's up so
our question is we are kind of having a
disagreement over what to do with our
money
as of august we are completely debt free
and we currently have 35 000 in our
joint savings account i hate it
house and everything is debt-free
um so we are military so we move
frequently and um we had we had to sell
our home in washington to move here to
alabama
um
and with the proceeds from that we
we paid off everything that we owned
student loan debt
and we have 35 000 right now we're
a joint income home we bring home about
six thousand dollars a month and
currently have four thousand dollars a
month going into savings
our disagreement is he wants to
use the money we currently have in our
account as a down payment
for
a mortgage
on a house that we cannot live in for
three
years okay and i would prefer to
save that money
and maybe wait a year which
if i do my math correctly without
interest that our account would be at
about 83 000 at that point
so you just not want to live on base
anymore
um so we wouldn't be buying a house here
we would continue to rent here um the
house would actually be back in
washington
why um because that's where we plan to
retire whenever he gets out of the
military when
he still has 10 years left
okay but we are projected to go back
yeah you shouldn't buy a house until
you're ready to go back yeah absolutely
not
so
the reason why is it's
it's it's a build it's not a perch i
guess it's technically still it doesn't
take 10 years to build a house correct
he
said that we could rent it out during
the meantime i'm sure but i don't
necessarily want strangers living in my
forever home for me to have to fix
before i move back in yeah there are no
forever homes um everybody moves uh just
about the time you think you have a
forever home you'll discover forever is
not there um so that's that's bogus but
i don't want people living in your i
don't want renters living in it either
no you don't buy a rental property that
you're gonna move into later just wait
until you get ready to buy right until
you get you don't want to be a landowner
yeah
when you when you come out of the
military you'll build your house where
you want to live yeah
and even then it's not a forever home
how much of this is he he is trying to
put an
end date on this thing
is this a psychological move for him
so
our goal was if we were to use this as a
down payment we'd want the house paid
off before he got out of the military
um in order for us to have
a dual income after he retires with his
retirement income from the military
and
uh start a woodworking business
and so here's what it sounds like sounds
like y'all are
in a hard season right now and y'all
have created a fantasy of what's gonna
the world's gonna be like in a decade
for y'all and it's cool to have goals
and to
paint pictures but y'all are watching a
lot of hgtv and you have a fantasy about
what the a decade for now is going to
look like and that's cool and all
but let it be there until you get there
i'd much rather you have
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
or whatever you want to do when you buy
a house
then
go buy something now that you're going
to strap yourself to on the other side
of the country
for a world that you don't know what's
going to exist in 10 years you move a
renter into this property i'll give you
a 90 probability you never live in it
ever
well
to be honest you said what i wanted to
hear
he won't like it
yeah so neither one of you win the
argument though yeah so i'd put the 35
000 and whatever you're going to say per
month into a good growth stock mutual
fund or a series of them meeting with
the smartvestor pro and that's your
house fund and then have enough money
saved up to pay cash for a house when
you come out of the military and uh if
you are coming out of the military in
nine months and you want to start the
build that's fine but nine years nah
don't think i would do that and just do
the math on what you think you're going
to earn
in rental income over the next day it's
just like the math doesn't work it's not
worth it no no and and you're not going
to move in that house after those
renters you're just not going to do it
you're going to end up having to gut it
and do everything else to get them to
get it back to be in your no don't do
that and by the way you'd be buying a
house in the most bonkers market ever
wait a decade
uh yeah this is not the time to buy
unless you really really need to buy
right
open phones at triple eight thank you
for your service great great call open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money okay
let's go to michael in dayton ohio hey
michael how are
you hey how you doing dave can you hear
me well absolutely what's up
hey i just had a question about w-4s i
don't make too much money i only make
like 32 out of the year
and what's the best way to where you
don't have to owe taxes at the end of
the year but you give the kgb i mean the
irs
enough to where you're just getting the
maximum your paycheck
um well there's two ways to do this or
three ways to do this one way the
simplest way is if you have made the
same amount of money for a while
how long have you made 32
hello
michael
yeah can you hear me yeah now i can you
need to turn that stupid phone off
speaker and talk into it okay now um the
how long have you made 32
uh i've made that for probably two years
now
okay did you get a tax refund in the
last two years
no i owed money last year i owed about
800 bucks okay then you're not having
enough taken out did you owe money the
year before
no that was the first time that i voted
money
okay how much does your refund the year
before
uh i think the year before it was about
150 to 200 bucks okay you're pretty
close then
i mean
and so you know yeah you're not having
enough taken out if you're having to pay
extra in
when you get there and if you end up
having to pay too much extra and they're
going to penalize you for not having
enough withheld
eventually so
uh but you know 800 bucks a month is
what 80 bucks i mean 800 is like 80
bucks a month so
um
you know you may want to have that much
more taken out of your account the
second way to that's the quick and dirty
way to do it the second way to do it is
actually do your taxes
and calculate what your taxes are going
to be and make sure that amount is
withheld out of your check
and then you'll be exact
um and
the third way is to do your taxes you
know that's pretty much it yes there's
two ways said so that's how you do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
hey if you hadn't found out this year
christmas is in december
yeah you knew that and the stress was
already starting to build up for you
wasn't it hey the stress over the food
the travel even the gifts no reason to
stress like that doesn't have to be that
way you can lay out a plan you can have
confidence you can have control you can
have peace in your finances we call it
financial peace we'll show you how to do
it in financial peace university we've
done that with about 10 million folks
now where we teach them how to get out
of debt
how to save money
how to become wealthy and outrageously
generous and how to put a plan into
practice with budgeting with the world's
best budgeting tool the every dollar app
the premium version so financial peace
university in the premium version of
every dollar comes with a ramsey plus
membership you don't have to live
through a stressed out christmas you can
give this to your friends your relatives
that need it or you can get started
with a free trial
of ramsey plus remember financial peace
university in every dollar
just go to
ramseysolutions.com slash ramsay plus
and sign up for your free trial it's not
that hard grace is with us grace is in
cincinnati hi grace how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i am 20 years old um i am about halfway
through college
and i've racked about wrapped up about
17 000
in student loan debt
i am currently
at the point where i am not really in
college anymore for myself
i'm in college for my parents
i really want to go get my real estate
license and
drop out
essentially
i'm at the point where i am making about
25 000 a year to 30 000 a year um
working a full-time job
i'm in a school as a non-traditional
student i'm attending online and night
classes
and i'm just at the point where i feel
like it's almost a hindrance to my goals
but i want to make my parents happy
what are you studying
i'm in business school like business
undecided marketing
and you have two years to finish
yeah i i've i've gotten to about 75
credit hours and i need about 130 to
graduate
how old are you 20 i'm 20. you still
live at home no i live on my own okay
so your parents want you to do this they
want you to go to school once you get
your degree
um but they're not paying for it
no they're not okay
well let me tell you you framed this in
such a way that you were trying to
control our answer
okay okay
because you you desperately wanted i
mean you know you wanted us to say oh
you don't need to make your parents
happy you need to go live your life and
and so you you completely put that
together that way i'll go ahead and tell
you ahead of time however
um
i don't want you to do either one
okay um i'm gonna choose c none of the
above
i would finish that degree
for you
okay while getting your real estate
license
i've got a degree in finance with a
specialization in real estate i got my
real estate license when i turned 18
years old and i worked 40 to 60 hours a
week for four years while i went through
school selling real estate
so i did exactly
what you're talking about doing and what
i'm prescribing for you
okay now you've got to go sell some
stinking houses because you're going to
quit your full-time job or you're going
to work a part-time job with your
full-time real estate career with your
full-time
go to school thing
but you're going to be glad when you're
30 that you finished up this marketing
degree for you not for them or for me or
for john it's going to be valuable to
you
um i think
i think because i think it's a good
field of study and it'll help you with
the real estate business if you spend
the next 20 years selling houses a
marketing degree will be helpful to you
and you'll be glad you spent the
academic
uh rigor
to insert these things into your
brain but i wouldn't want you to do it
for your mom and i wouldn't want you to
do it for me i'm asking you to do it for
you it is again i'll tell you what i did
i'll also tell you this
selling real estate's tough selling real
estate when you're 20 is even tougher um
and that's not a that's not me putting
you down i've just been there done that
and when i was 19 years old and i'm
trying to sell a 45 year old or a 60
year old a house
it was hard to have credibility with
them to help to help them make that
decision harder than it is when you have
a 40 year old talking to a 40 year old
you see what i'm saying so it's uh this
is a very large transaction for someone
and they're looking at a very young
person who's assisting them so you're
going to have to develop a level of
professionalism post haste
okay which i think i've gotten with my
little experience and internships not
the extent that i think a 40 year old
would have per se but
um
i guess my other question for you would
be
i i don't necessarily have the funds to
be a full-time student and i really
don't want to go any further in debt
i don't want you to either but you're
you know all this is about is work and
earning you just got to earn enough to
pay for it yeah
and if you need to drop down and
go take nine hours one semester that's
great yeah and you can make more than
twenty five thousand dollars a year
which you're making now to sean real
estate
yeah
if you get even as a 20 year old right i
mean
even though you got an uphill battle and
you know you walk with an extra swagger
you walk with a little extra uh strut on
your on your gate
confidence uh poise
uh because that's that way they can
trust you but you got to be actually
knowing what you're doing and also well
you're doing all this but i think you
can do it um
but i just wouldn't
i don't think it's an either or i i hope
you hear the wisdom in what dave told
you
the
the the law your ability to be against
something
runs out of time
you get exhausted by that
it's much easier and the legs are longer
when you are for something you're going
towards something you want and you've
turned for some reason and we could
probably talk on this for a couple of
weeks
for some reason you've turned the idea
of education
as a battle between you and your parents
and not as a way for you to pave the way
for the rest of your life and for you to
learn some new skills and you to become
a ninja
you've turned it into a well my mom
wants me to do it so i don't want to
and at least that's how you framed it to
us i'm with dave i'd love to see you
finished and if your school is no good
find a cheaper alternative transfer in
you're halfway through this is when a
lot of people transfer get a school
where you're going to be picking up some
good information but i i'm with dave man
i want to see you work really really
hard graduate it takes you three years
to do two years worth of work because
you're selling real estate all the time
and you're working a side job delivering
uber i don't care i did that yeah
scratch and claw baby grind you're 20.
you got you got nothing but energy
you're not gonna die from hard work
right before you die you pass out you'll
be okay
and don't spite yourself
don't don't yeah cut your own toes off
just to show somebody yeah exactly
exactly mom and dad aren't in the
equation anymore yeah except that they
just get to cheer from the sidelines or
boo from the sidelines but that's their
decision yeah that's not your decision
but um
you know you you're right i hadn't
thought about that there's a lot more
energy in working for something than
against always always
you can only work against something
until the anger runs out well or what
happens is you solve that problem and
your identity has shifted from i want to
solve this problem too i'm someone who
just goes looking for fights and now i'm
fighting out in the street for something
that i don't even care about anymore
we're just fighting that they don't talk
about me though
john john is in colorado springs hey
john what's up
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call you guys are my heroes oh you too
sir how can we help you
um my question is how do you
appropriately
ask your employer for a raise
two things
uh i'm an employer of over a thousand
people number one ask how you can add
value that would make how can i what can
i do here how can i add value to this
organization that would make you die to
pay me more money
you come in my office and ask that i'll
give you a list of things to do and then
i'll pay you more money
because you added more value number one
number two uh you're underpaid for a an
area that is very definable and they can
do an easy compensation study on that
area and you know you're you're a
project you're a pm too you're project
manager you're in pm2 and pm2s all make
x and you're only making y
and you show evidence
if a pm2 walks into our offices and go
look hey here's a study we go oh we've
already got the study so but we're ahead
of you but you know if they had done
that in the past before we had the comp
studies done and said you know here's a
realistically people like me make this
now and can i what can i do to make sure
that this happens here i don't want to
be i'm not trying to be rude but i just
want to be helpful and um we go oh my
god you're kidding well we look at it
too and we agree then we're going to
raise your pay because we want to pay
street rate on what you are because we
don't want you to leave for street rate
i'm not going to pay you double street
rate just because you think your mama
thought you were pretty but i'm going to
pay you what street rate is on the job
you get paid for the job man
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
rhoda and randy are with us in phoenix
says on my screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
[Music]
how much have you paid off
355 thousand dollars
yes
how long did this take
four and a half years oh man look at you
guys and uh what was your range of
income during this time
we started off with 85 000 and we ended
at 140. excellent very good
and what kind of debt was this uh
355 thousand dollars
oh it's it was a mixed salad it was uh
credit cards all sorts of credit cards
we had some fun tax debt we had
uh medical bills and our home
[Music]
paid your household yes you're weird
people
way to go you guys wow
that is so awesome what is this house
worth
well
we actually just uh
looked at zillow just recently and it
said uh just over six hundred thousand
wow
how old are you two
i am 41 and i'm 42. and you have a paid
for house worth 600 grand
yes we do how much is in your 401ks and
your retirement accounts
we have
378
000. you're millionaires
yeah if you have a honda accord in the
driveway you made it
wow congratulations 40 year old baby
steps millionaires i'm so proud of y'all
way to go
way to go
all right tell us the story what
happened how'd you get intersected with
ramsay five years ago and start four and
a half years ago start on this process
oh well it's it's actually really
interesting story so
rhode and i met on a reality tv show yep
about six six years ago five years ago
um
and
part of the tv show is there was a
matchmaker
and our matchmakers while at a lunch one
day
they
uh we were sitting down eating and i
bought appetizers all sorts of fun stuff
and
and they
had cash and they're like well this is
what we had budgeted and they put the
cash out there and we're like this is
weird why
why aren't you chipping in all this
other stuff and they're like well we
have a strict budget
and when you get married you share the
same finances and and i i remember
thinking we were dating at the time and
i was starting to sweat thinking what
would happen
with you know my future wife sharing the
same account and also and
and the matchmaker basically looked at
me like you guys got to get it together
you should check out dave ramsey wow
yeah so as god god had it he opened up
the doors uh i listened to the radio
and then rhoda was working at a church
and at the church of that very week
they had a fpu class starting
and we went and we drank the kool-aid
and we've never turned back
i love it
peace university comes through the
reality show in the church who knew
yeah
love it very cool you guys that's
incredible very cool and here you are 40
something early 40s with a paid for
house and your baby steps millionaires
i'm so proud of you guys all right who
are your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
so our friends courtney and blake they
also did dave ramsey and they did the
free screen they came over there
um they were on our back when we first
told them that we started this program
they're like you guys need to be on it
and so they kept cheering us on when we
first started they talked to us about
like life insurance and all of that
literally like calling us to make sure
we got stuff done so
they were really awesome
but also our financial like advisor
smart visitor we got paired up with like
the most amazing amazing smart vista we
love him so much he was
he pushed us to pay this house off yeah
dave when you say that smart investors
need to have
a heart of a teacher our smart investor
alex he really you know he held her hand
he educated us he walked us through it
he
showed us that you know money isn't just
green there it it actually multiplies if
you do it the right way
and it was really really cool and he
killed us he held us very accountable so
if somebody's listening
and they say i want to be a 42 year old
baby steps millionaire with a paid for
house and everything paid off what do
you tell them the key is
hmm
besides obviously join a reality show
right we know that
for us i am a first generation african
so we have like two completely cultural
backgrounds that this was just like
going to be impossible for us
so i would say god first prayer the
bible says in proverbs 3 5 that in all
your ways
acknowledge him and who direct your past
and we definitely kept our goals and
prayed over them
every time we took a step we prayed and
prayed
and
budget meetings
that was big big
budget meetings making sure that you are
always looking and making sure that
those uh those little dollars don't have
a mind of its own you know yeah um i
think what really helped out the most
especially for for me is um i i believe
in that whole proximity principle like
you keep the those podcasts going you
hear how relatable how people help
people from grocery stores and every
walks of life can can do it they could
be an everyday millionaire they can pay
off all their debt
and it becomes so real and the more
you're
the more we were around it
uh we were like okay this is this is
this is good and then we went to fpu
three times wow uh we we did a few live
twice and um randy went to um
wow
well thank you guys well you guys are an
impressive impressive young couple very
very very well done
so we got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story you're there towards that baby
steps millionaire thing happening so
very very well done and uh extra copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away for somebody who's just starting
on their journey maybe you're going to
be like those matchmakers where you'll
be showing them how to do it i like that
so uh yeah way to go you guys very very
proud of you you are heroes you're very
impressive all right rhoda and randy
phoenix arizona 355
000 paid off four and a half years at 41
and 42 years old they are baby steps
millionaires
making 85 to 140 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
arizona i'm telling you man i think we
blew some speakers out that's impressive
very cool you guys
very cool
we're getting to talk to more more and
more of those every day can i tell you
what's cool
um
one of the unsung heroes in that story
is the
matchmaker
who is just living their life this is
how i do stuff and somebody who's a real
handsome guy is like i don't order
appetizers around the table and they
said well you're free to do that
this is how i'm choosing to live my life
and that's a bold move in that industry
in that setting everyone's trying to
impress everybody and that person said
uh you need to if you all are getting
married you're like ought to be on the
show please check yourself before you
like yourself that's right man be on the
same page with your money and yeah wow
what a cool what a cool story see i'm
starting to meet after being on the air
for 30 years thousands and thousands of
stories just like that that have become
baby steps millionaires following the
baby steps
and that's why we did this new book that
we put on pre-sale this week baby steps
a millionaire i'm so excited for you man
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can do you can
pre-order it at ramsey solutions right
now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today ephesians 2 4-5 but
because of his great love for us god who
is rich in mercy made us alive with
christ even when we were dead in
transgressions
it is by grace
that you have been saved
helen keller said life is a succession
of lessons
which much must be lived
to be understood
no question about it open phones this
hour dr john dolone ramsey personality
is my co-host justin is in pittsburgh hi
justin welcome to the ramsey show
hey john thanks so much taking my call
really appreciate it sure what's up
uh yeah so the the reason for my call is
uh apparently 28 years old i've been in
a relationship with my girlfriend for
the past two years and i'm thinking
about taking that relationship to the
next step
here pretty soon cool she is a
veterinarian who just graduated uh last
year and is going to bring about 350 000
worth of student loan debt into uh our
marriage lord congratulations
wow so i guess i guess i really just
wanted to call i've been you know i'm
new to the show and do to you guys but
i've been doing date like things for the
last
three to four years and was just curious
what your advice would be in regards to
how
we can plan to make those repayments
once we we get married as well as how we
prioritize that um against other
large life um you know purchases such as
a house you know vehicles things on
those lines
that's a hard one how much debt do you
have outside of that 350 how much debt
do you are you gonna bring into this
relationship uh nothing completely debt
free um you have been saving and
investing for for quite some time i have
about twenty one thousand dollars in
cash uh
sixty thousand dollars in uh my
traditional uh savings plan our tsp and
um
uh 401k
and as well as about uh investor
portfolio of a hundred and ten thousand
dollars okay that's helpful what do you
do what do you make
um so apparently this year i just got
back from a nine month deployment so i'm
gonna make somewhere around 107
uh this year and then on track make like
135
next year
projection wise
okay
and so obviously your military thank you
for your service
i appreciate it all right here's the
thing
um the number one cause of divorce in
north america money fights and money
problems money stress
you are walking into
a a mess
she has made an unbelievably large mess
um and you guys have as part of your
pre-marriage counseling
have got to
because you have an unusually large mess
you've got to go unusually deep
in your relationship and in your
agreement on what our short-term and
long-term future looks like
uh if she says uh if she's going to play
i and i have no idea okay but there's
kind of two ends of the spectrum here if
she's gonna roll up her sleeves and
bleep be blue collar and go oh my god
we've made a mess
we're gonna dive on this thing we're
gonna we're gonna fix this thing i'm
gonna work like a maniac i'm gonna uh
work with every sick puppy in an 800
mile radius as a veterinarian i'm going
to work my
tail end off and i'm going to make 200
000 a year while you make a hundred
thousand a year we're gonna put your
hundred thousand out of your
investments towards this and we're going
to clean this stinking mess up in two
years
now you got a woman you can marry
if she's like oh well you know it might
take us 30 years and i don't really want
to work that much
i went and spent 350 000 to become a
veterinarian but i'm not going to
veterinary much
run
run yeah now she's she's definitely
fantastic and you know i know she's
fantastic that wasn't what i asked
so is is she all in brother is she in on
the work part
she's she's in on the work part uh you
know she definitely
when when she looks at the the grand
amount uh you know our heart kind of
pounds a little bit so i definitely
think that it's uh something that's on
the tip of her mind um but you know with
with our goals what branch of the
military are you in
uh navy sir yep what do you do
uh well so i'm in the the reserves
actually so um i'm a supply guy in the
navy and then uh i i work in the oil gas
field as a program manager so gotcha
okay this is a program to be managed
it's exactly what this is
and here's the deal the deeper you
sacrifice in hours of work and in lack
of lifestyle the faster this mess goes
away the faster this mess goes away the
higher the probability is that it's
going to go away and you don't crash in
the middle of it and the faster it goes
away obviously the faster you can go
become very very wealthy
and you can back your hours back down
where you can breathe again but both of
you are going to be working like maniacs
and you're going to live on nothing and
you're going to drain every account
that's not a retirement account you're
going to throw it at this after the
honeymoon and you guys are living on a
budget that's beans and rice rice and
beans and she's working all the
time
until she cleans this mess up
okay and then one more thing i want to
throw at you you can you got capacity
for one more
absolutely john all right
you agree to this and you walk down that
aisle this is not going to be you versus
her
this is going to be you with her right
and so i know especially i know guys who
like to flex and say well if you hadn't
and if you had once you're in y'all are
in this together and so the shame part's
over then it's just y'all about y'all
digging and building it's not about her
digging something out and you just
standing there watching it as she digs
right we're all in this together is that
fair
absolutely that's awesome that's awesome
good man the problem becomes ours and
the opportunity becomes out that's right
both and and listen here's the thing
you guys will come out of this so
freaking strong oh man and you will be
you will your relationship will be so
strong and your your character will be
so strong if you bust up into this but
if you screw around with this this is a
mountain and it'll bury you guys
that's what i'm concerned about yeah so
you got it's got to be like game on and
all her friends coming out of vet school
are going to get new lexus
and all that stuff
they can all jump in the creek man
because they're dumber than rocks
they're going they're going to make a
mess i'm telling you man you're going to
be so laser focused but the beautiful
thing is that's going to knit you all
together
like a because you're fighting a common
foe a common enemy
and you you're knitted together it's
gonna it's gonna do stuff in the dna of
your relationship that uh the easy times
won't bring to your relationship
absolutely so it's a huge opportunity if
you approach it right and you're both
fully committed to it but it's a huge
problem if either one of you are going
to be half buttoning this thing
so you're like blaming her or she's like
going to be a little princess or
whatever with a vet coat on i mean you
know no you got run
run away
you know that's the thing if that's the
case but i don't think that's her
i i think she's special and um and i
know you are after talking to you yeah
so i think you guys can do it but the
this is the parameters this is the
boundaries by which this huge mess
becomes a blessing
to your
family generationally because you'll be
telling the grandkids with the with the
uh
uh marshmallows on the end of a stick
someday 50 years from now well back in
the day when your granny got out of veg
school we didn't have nothing
and we had to work
and we had to sweat i had my that's why
you're here on the back of this mountain
and we on the whole stinking mountain
and you're doing your marshmallow here
kid
this is your story man and grandma had
her arm halfway up a cows you know
but we got it paid off we gotta pay it
off
you could have never gone there and we'd
have been okay
hey man if i'm grandma that's what i'm
pulling out
[Laughter]
and you went playing your oil and gas i
had to stick my eye to go shoulder deep
to get this debt paid off but i did it
but i did it
oh you are wrong that's awesome
well that's it i mean you got you got to
have the story it's like when you're
getting out you're driving a junk car
you're driving a hooptie you need to
give the hoopty a name and you need to
take pictures of it yep it needs to be
on the wall never forget the hoopty it's
the never this is why we're here no more
because we did this yes and that changes
everything and there's nothing wrong
with telling those stories that's what
families are made of that are that have
substance to them right it's good stuff
and you're getting ready to build one of
those justin proud of you man
john glad to have you on the show until
the last three minutes but um
james good show laura good show that
puts us out of the ramsey shop in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus or a family
member that needs a daily dose of ramsay
advice in their life let them know about
the ramsey call of the day podcast it's
a quick hit of advice about life and
money in under 10 minutes check out the
ramsey call of the day podcast wherever
you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you